sur ce faux sang, l'huître Shapiro sir Bay
News dit que mon singe regardait-il
au moins [ __ ] oui j'ai fait une circulaire
dans au moins Lapidus pomme de terre suprême
j'ai vu que sur le schéma politique le
projet de loi des missionnaires avant moi j'ai dit la
boîte du Messie oh merci
ses gardiens appréciables rasa le premier
entraîneur de la LCF était maman Apoc parce que tout
bouddhisme de la société jerk à prendre oui des devoirs était
une vidéo de surveillance Oh Sebastian
sociopathe un exorciste
alors massez la gauche et tout le modèle de tsukumo
apparaît n'importe où
Roberto Orci à la crème accomplie nous
ne voyons pas la si vallée  fille tu veux
faire la raison du baiser mais Raghu Rama Navami
un
perdant de participation satirique salut elle panique quand il a dit
le kiddo de la société Madame Savino et
si je voulais finir le roi
waluigi Rasputia les Philippins s'entraînent pour MA
souvenir ooh la plaque de diffusion VFA
beaucoup de purge James ceci  soir nous
n'en avons qu'un de plus ça s'appelle
le choix de Bobby quelle vue a
survécu la purge de cette année l'âme de
notre pays est en jeu  la purge
cible les pauvres le péché va gagner
elle va changer mcgrill - il est
temps de faire quelque chose pour ça sénateur
la purge doit prendre fin tu
prends beaucoup de risques sénateur je dois j'étais
le seul de mes  famille pour survivre à
ce que je postule pour ce poste j'ai
presque fait quelque chose que j'encouragerai des
nuits et des années en arrière Je veux cette
nuit je veux des hommes dans toutes ces pièces nous avons des
yeux et des oreilles sur tout d'
accord
commençons c'est votre émission d'urgence  système
annonçant le début de la
purge annuelle à la sirène tous les crimes,
y compris le meurtre, seront légaux pendant 12
heures votre gouvernement vous remercie de
votre participation quelqu'un nous a trahis
ce n'est pas un exercice
nous sommes seuls et un en ce
moment
sénateur venez avec nous  vous comprenez
ce qui est en jeu, vous,
il est de notre devoir de l'aider à la protéger, vous
pensez
que l'Amérique est bénie pour nous avoir permis de purger
et de purifier nos âmes, rejoignez-moi alors que nous
éliminons les personnes perverses.
rge
fait